so let's say you're lost in the woods
first of all what the hell how are you
lost in the woods hell do you not have
an emergency plan and map a cell phone
something but okay let's say you're lost
in the woods that say forces unknown
have dropped you off here and left you
to fend for yourself okay you know that
giving you no references from the
outside world let's say it's cloudy as
it is so you don't know where the Sun is
you know that humans will generally
wander in a very large circle around and
around and around until they collapse
from exhaustion but you know if you keep
going in one direction if you manage to
keep going straight then you might well
survive but how do you know you're
keeping in one direction without a
compass or a map well you should know
this is something that most people know
that moss grows on the north side of
trees like this because Moss prefers
damp conditions dark conditions in the
northern hemisphere the north side is
going to be damper and dark because the
Sun will normally shy on the south it's
opposite of course in the southern
hemisphere Suns mostly in the north
there so muscle will grow on the south
but I'm currently in the northern
hemisphere I know that much at least so
this must be the north side of the tree
no no actually that's not true at all
because North is that way
north side of the tree no moss because
it's actually much more complicated in
that which is something you might not
know you should not use moss for
emergency navigation because the
microclimates in the area particularly
here in Ravenna Park in Seattle this is
just a a ravine with very little in the
way of Sun from any direction the
microclimate here means that the west
side of the tree is actually going to be
the darkest and dankest and moss East so
if you're in a flat plane in perfect
conditions well perhaps it might help
you but for emergency navigation your
best idea well look let's put it this
way
I'm not Bear Grylls the best way of
surviving is not to get lost in the
woods in the first place
you